hello I existed a boat and I am here to
convert Anna Mae convention I have not
been an ax or million but I imagine
they're really nice people so before I
go into this I have taken a very small
amount of LSD when I play I do this to
make things look a little bit more
exciting because my guess is NMA are
very very boring people so hopefully I
would see anything too strange to alert
me
I think this stuff is too strong I
decided to take this dear because
clearly there was a something bitstream
to be read
my hope is that will not see anything on
the street is that because every that
was very mature
and very sweet
the Klan was finding ways it may be
are you laying the skirt
that makes sense
make sense today
where are the norm I need to favorite
movie the humor was playing this week
seen in my life
how about you we have to see thinking
back to all the movies today
you're its boys my mind is blown
this is think I'm stealing car he's a
jackass because of cooling everything is
bruising Kara
do gun good rock guns do-rag except what
they we pull the trigger and they kill
people to do that
shouting the phony ramage anything right
here is effective endurance Dunson way
yeah he's done an awesome arse at all
buying to your guns have orange things
on the front of them that's where it
makes them stand out to you know make
them look like guys they're digging
Pokemon and well with Team Rocket flying
around for 10 years they please
completely copy about doing anything
about it
yeah I'm gonna take care of this problem
myself obviously you do a very good job
essential service till eat Iranian
I like cheese Twilight that's the
greatest movie I've ever seen in my life
no wait please at the book yeah the book
sucks people are pushing me they're very
inconsiderate to change verses obviously
that's
though your soul
thank you so much Casper I knew ye when
can I keep you oh it's still creepy
Oh
that was the part of the show where
because of my Nellie's fee I will look
at this for an hour
here
the human sperm giant-ass - what do I
win what do I win
good lord some people just don't get it
dude over there an imposter
I know who are you I know I am who you
anyway who are you who are you
I believe that I of dinies Isis that you
believe that is digestion I believe that
you believe that I believe it's ro world
this is a twin brother convention he is
obviously the evil twin cousin dick okay
my shirt says WYSIWYG yer says y zy what
the word is pronounced is
may lead you to another doo-dah doo-dah
the only way to do this is a tutor but
whoever can get through to pop each
other first
I win I'll be the to even know you to do
the judo apheresis for a while
oh shit don't cross the streams
our readers does that cardboard up
defender for the legend even pass them
know sign language okay
me happy
do you think means
I don't have a cellphone but just yell
very loud in a pile of your wax canvas
this is austerity for 500 shiny it's
like the ammo for like a really huge
good wait a minute I know what this is
this is a jolly rancher everybody take
in
are you opens witnesses to stormtroopers
clearly I need glasses cuz I'm seeing
four of everybody so even though I never
did find in or me I can safely say this
was the greatest convention I've ever
been to in my life of course it's the
only convention the bum has ever been to
but what does that ever stopped it from
being great
this is jittery bum sing Jen you got
yeah